hey somebody believes I'm a property
investor I make a lot of money duponte
but I'm also not on a mission to help
other people invest in property to most
people when they become successful in
property that I divide them disappear
I've always found that if I ever made it
successfully property I share openly and
freely and Here I am so last week I had
a whole bunch of people asking me
questions neatly questions detailed
questions read books recently all around
property investment how much money is
important and so on take some of those
questions from last week I'm going to do
the best I can right now on the spot
however if you've got questions about
property neatly questions and I can help
you comment them below in the video and
then next week when a new video I'll
answer your question so anything that
all are on property investment making
money as a problem from a comment below
I'd love and I read every comment but
they can't respond to every single one
blow do be all comments so lastly we had
a lady called Danielle they've been you
lately maybe who knows but this person
said what are your thoughts on concrete
houses I currently own one but um put
off one another by two layers I feel
that I'm always going to be capped as
mortgage companies don't like lending on
them Thanks yeah I'm going to be great
okay so comfy house family doesn't know
is a non-standard construction house so
if it's just building bricks just a new
construction house then it's just inside
it's secure and it's easy to lend on the
house if it's a concrete house or
anything of non-standard construction or
a wooden house or anything other than
just traditional rates what happens is
the lenders get it then if you want to
buy a house like that the names of some
time aside
and now what that does is that you buy
the house normally come on quite sure
which so you might see a house she's
only a hundred grand and we'll wait
really wow the others in the street
rather than 50 grams awesome but it's
non-static construction so you'll buy
and you're went out really well other
than when you come to sell it that those
get down to fight with the mortgage
which is a bit of 20 like 90% the buyers
on the net to buy it
so you cap you market and then they do
something better so I don't I like
personally only personal instruction
because I'd like to have more business
of my houses because then it gives me
more return the best of them so would I
buy another non-static construction
house or concrete house Danielle no I
think it's counting Gallagher he says
hey Sam you said you can have some one
question from us we call sorry but you
don't go around to it could could you do
in the next video
alright short man when you say I have to
no money out so much money in then put a
lot of the money how do you do that
okay I think what you're saying is a be
really important here here's the answer
Cameron Gallagher like this video right
now so you buy a house and you buy it on
the below market value or you buy it and
then you push the value up so let's say
I buy a house for 1,000 pounds but
there's a problem in the house there's
Japanese knotweed now I know that if
there was no Japanese knotweed the house
would be a hundred fifty thousand pound
but because this Japanese knotweed in
the government which is a deadly plant
and it puts me off oh no it's only
laundromat but I also know with the ten
thousand pound
we sold it out in demand control and I
can push the value back up to 150 okay
that's the case study so how how pretty
would William I buy the house for cash
from $2,000 borrow like a bridging I'm
gonna buy from two thousand and then
spent 10 hours of sewing out the issue
in this example Japanese not wait so I'm
not gonna 2010 but I've pushed the value
of twelve hundred fifty thousand now
that I do is like a mortgage school
mortgage on my house objects near true
that you haven't even fifty thousand
house which means they'll let me
75% of one hundred and fifty thousand
pounds which is I think it's one two
thousand panel if you say so fifty
thousand pounds point seven five to
twelve thousand pounds I do good so what
about you that hundred twelve thousand
pound movie well I paid back that the
bridging loan company I pay all the
putting on that pulling back out so
that's how it will look so to do these
strategies we buy we furnish we finance
rent
that's the strategies fantastic strategy
and it's all the time probably in pull
me out we sucking your cash and that one
room is how it works if that is not
gonna like I don't know what that smash
be like but drop your comments if that's
you you know questions like yeah but how
many fathers houses or get question
comment your questions below
guess what I'll probably answer it next
week okay and the you what other people
are you targeting and going after the
one to lease option agreements and bring
two radios what type of person or
property owners will do these types of
deals okay so people that want to give
you their house on a rental agreement or
people don't want any hassle okay so
people that maybe and someone is really
busy maybe someone who's got lots and
lots of properties
you know why maybe someone was just
tired they're sick of being in our world
and then you rather get less money and
they'll give you that house and you get
that a monthly rent
and then you're managing but then you'll
keep the difference they don't mind you
might be brendham up from one house they
don't care how dependable I just don't
want to have to have any phone calls
because I'll go long and because I'm so
happy find those possibilities I think
I'll do the question similar someone
lives will they carry cherry or a lovely
name said can you let us know which
websites are best for finding properties
for each of the options you recommend
for rent around hmm these documents etc
so how do we find these people or you
can network you can attend seminars and
networking programs and events or even
on websites and depending on what kind
of deal you looking forward appear on
the website you go to so for rent
immense I can take on a spare room like
only you get I can't go through open
waits before went to serviced
accommodation apartments as well
if you're looking for lease option
agreement under to Brighton and ice
cream there and while the negative
equity leads well all this stuff is
stuff that we do lie at the property
investors grass board so you if you
comes he beats the castles you know if
you mix the grass balls dr. comment tell
me your experience what happens is we
dig up the phone and we keep line calls
we find the lion deals and you see it
and once you've seen it you can never
unsee it in a good way so another thing
is this when you go when you're good
networking people have dashboards
telling people the flying the crash
horse from Saudi Arabia is right here in
India had a lot of money and then you
can pitch them you've been like a you
belong
yeah I've got five remotes okay would
you like a guaranteed wax plank or yeah
I'm going back to India next week okay
would you like someone to do adventure
he's got a lot of time that can run
around on the road in the UK maybe we
can like having these kind of
conversations could you come to the
crash course when you come don't just
sit in the same chair mix the same
person for the whole two days like Nick
work because you get a lot of business
done as well so I'll get Ollie the leap
is one in the description crash course
two days on me on that
so get cellphone tiny people yet you'll
love it perhaps next a new how can I
stop a flipping company awesome
I don't think so I think that's probably
not the best idea and here's why so when
you buy a house and then do it up and
sell it you want to do it in a trending
market so in different areas on the up
and the you buy a house and then you say
great London zone pray he's not training
a little man it's very standard it's
like so and people are very scared at
the moment so it's not really a seller's
market it's more buyers so if you buy a
house would buy the good price you could
do it up but then selling at the end
right now many of them probably 100
people want to buy a house push the
value of the little B 5 upset the shore
and that could work with some other
London Soho perhaps I can I don't mean
to ruin your dreams man
I'm just I'm just here to tell you truth
so sometimes people say something you
make it sound all too easy
I've noticed sharing your experience of
being a property investor so sometimes
it's hard it's easy if you do the right
strategy
my knowledge if you're in the wrong area
with the wrong strategy with the wrong
moment it's really hard so anyway what
was Nick shires Mohammed step by step
how do you become a compliant deal salsa
okay so there's quite a few steps to
becoming a compliant deal sorcerer we
are actually myself and some of my
students have written a book all about
property compliance about Lease Option
women's contracts and it works fine
exactly how to do this have to become
compliant step by step I'll leave a link
in the comments to that book you can get
on Amazon I think nine pounds
ninety-nine and it's very very good book
so you can get that okay well we've got
SME
says I've had an offer accepted on a bit
low market value merely repossessed
property being sold by Bank solicitors
are being instructed with the property
names on the market what happens if the
bank accepts a higher offer does it
become a race to exchange contracts
first any boss will be very appreciative
thank you okay SM unfortunately yes I
thought the bearer of bad news on this
video if you do I'm a repossessed house
and it's being sold by banking white a
traditional banks work when they sell
the house is they'll put it on the
market so realistically thank you young
bright move anything like that
you're wonderful forward if the offers
accepted what they'll do is in the
description to the property on Rightmove
aware as we this Lee they're sad the
property of them offer accepted of X if
you wish to put a higher offering please
do so so what happens is they want it to
go like this now it might not you can
put forward your offer and just hope
that no one goes oh [ __ ] but yeah that
is how they work unfortunately
normally by an individual if you solve
anything new to offer properties except
it doesn't offer market and if some
firms of the evidence
that was accepted the agent said because
having that as confidential is sold so I
think I'm just having that risk what I
would suggest is should you never buy
repossessed property for my back
no necessarily but don't become
emotionally attached if you have if you
have an offer accepted great white and
even continue with that but just bare
mine you could be is that Alright next
football straight to you
yes how do you funding but we don't know
what that has to do with their property
anymore in order to find someone who's
willing to allow you to take over the
property would pay later on down the
line do such degrees a lot of these same
questions so pick up the phone
that's it pick up the phone don't go
tree and find people that can sell their
properties list properties to be listed
two months are really up and say why
aren't you semi what can I do
just just just put yourself out there
get them to get around the bestest so
that's for sure Carson cash to invest
but I also need someone's lately it's
Justin's how best to use the money yes
do not buy a house you didn't want to
live in you should rent somewhere and
then with the hundred grounds you should
be invested in little little right
investing legal and in the money you
make from the investments you should use
to pay your rent and believe me if you
mess right you'll have way more excess
as well that'd be my advice don't and I
was saying rent where you live and went
out what you are crazy a permit okay
we'll do this one only one in the
wrap-up so if you've got questions
comment
Craig says what's your opinion regarding
all suites in an HMO
by doing this it could increase tenet
the amount of rooms but concern about
whether it's worth the hassle and cost
as well as like a flexibility if the
properties we turn back into a normal
single another buyer in the future would
greatly appreciate your eyes and big
thank you for all the content you could
use today it helped me so much great
awesome great question I can tell the
intelligence of my listeners by their
questions and what are the biggest
YouTube channel the world of them is
like currently as we speak about
thirty-eight thousand subscribers but
the questions that are coming in are
good like I'm just so glad to hear and a
lot of people in the comments are doing
this on day now but so you guys are good
it's how great until you doing it you
questions intelligent so there's not a
straightforward answer to this question
so in my book which I wrote while I ran
high in 2016 I thought that once we to
the very negative wire leads on towards
our food the markets changed a little
bit because there's more HMOs now
there's more there's more demand than
ever
okay believe me this demand but there's
also more supply than ever so on sweets
do set you apart from a lot of the
supply and you typically depending on
what country you're talking about
fifteen hundred pounds maybe two
thousand pounds to put on sweet in in
the bakery
of course it depends on different
factors so I do often these days one
sweets in an event particularly if I
wanted to push the value up one of those
do you be a couple of things I would I
would look at the demand in the area I
look at the supply in the area and I
would speak to some HMO management
companies and just ask them
realistically how much is it gonna set
you apart
what difference in when is he going to
produce all about the return on
investment here when I put two thousand
pounds in four bedrooms but they
how does he lift the volume of the house
how much is it going to lift the rents
and what's the return on investment all
making that decision and if we generally
listen he's not really good then don't
do it if you are thinking of turning you
back into a single that because you're
not sure on the market that would
suggest you've probably looked a little
look do you do this in the first place
because it's forwards we terminated
strategy for us that's just small I get
it but if you think Iman's you don't let
this act know what you know then you
probably know because before you buy
houses packed about you want to do some
series if you do the jeans notice
applying the demand on the back in your
hand even spoken to all of the hmm
expert managers in the area so if you're
not sure and you feel about it rent it
out over that once we see how it goes
and then across the bridge in six months
because the last thing you want to do is
spend a load of money and then regret it
but all suites are definitely helpful in
a lot especially the air is saturated so
I know that's not black and white answer
because you can depend on the area these
different factors in bold or stupid on
your back that's how if you get all
Suites is having a quick we financial
end you've got 10,000 pound embankments
or there's a lot of different factors
but I hope that's given you some sort of
loser thought okay that's read sk8
Jackie said can you still refiners
same day so what that question means is
can you buy a house builder monkey value
for couch and then refines the center
yes that is in theory yes he anything
you used to be able to buy house below
mock you very much the same i believe
this
however they said back in 2009 2010 if
you can't do any one you have to wait
six months so you buy a house by the way
six
they scrap the six-month rule a lot of
members precise mortgages can't relax
they'll let you refocus straightaway
sandack no because before you refine
actually needs to increase the value of
the property
so you need to do the reefer you need to
fully fix the problem which is not gonna
be doing today so but if you buy a house
and say say it's got no kitchen and
bathroom or it is not really
mortgageable
and you buy it on bridging finance and
then you spent a month doing it up or
solving the kitchen and bathroom out for
two weeks you can refine out straight
away there's no limit but send a no so
that is my general advice I hope you
guys found this would feel helpful
I'm really excited to see anybody while
this would think that gives me more of a
kick than one people comments I things
like obviously vegetables and I've got
two meals or just a loving man so thank
you guys you great questions thank you
for taking action and becoming
successful in property I'm really glad
that these videos helped hope to see you
at the crash course well the way you can
come to the club this is not I don't
think anybody from from my property
training business so the crash course
their Academy I don't you take your
salary can't get paid for that is
because I absolutely love it and just
thank you guys but fully support on
YouTube and the crash courses and maybe
the Academy over the last few years
can't wait to see more the next video
please do subscribe
smash the like and comment below and
I've seen it
[Music]